when the inferno came
farmers in samora became firefighters
my god he says i'm all alone
in remote areas like this there is no
time to wait for a rescue crew you have
to save yourself
the wind whips up the flames in every
direction
it is easy to find yourself surrounded
i came out of nowhere
come on go go go
yeah you gotta get around this guy
days later manuel tills charred soil
putting out any remaining embers
we had help but from other farmers in
the area
the local government didn't help us at
all
it's very nice to come after the fire
and say we will pay for all of this but
the time to help us is when the fire is
here
the blaze burned crops destroyed
infrastructure and left behind economic
uncertainty
fires in this part of the country may be
under control for now but there is still
smoke hanging in the air you can see it
obscuring the landscape you can even
smell it for the people living here and
for those fire rescue teams that are
based here in tabara these are
ever-present reminders the wildfire
season is far from over
[Music]
for three generations yolanda mayo
julian's family has lived and worked on
this land
she watched their barn go up in flames
in minutes
taking stock
she says they don't know how they'll be
able to recover
i've never seen anything like this
before the fire came very quickly with a
lot of wind it was just relentless we
could do absolutely nothing it's still
going it still has a lot of power
there used to be hundreds of animals
here
most were moved but yolanda's family
could not save the hay the livestock
eats
even before the wildfires changed this
landscape life here was hard
families struggling just to make a
living are now scrambling to keep their
future from turning to ash
zain basravi al-jazeera
spain